[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heiße gibt es ein tolles plätzchen
rezept und zwar habe ich bis patienten
an plätzen gemacht die sehen so aus ist
und so keine thaler und die zubereitung
ist auch wirklich super einfach man hat
wirklich gar nicht so viel arbeit ich
habe hier im innern einen marzipan
pistazien kern außenrum richtig schöne
möbel teig und dann habe ich sie noch
dekoriert mit zartbitterschokolade oder
kuvertüre besser gesagt und pistazien
und ich werde es zuerst einmal den maps
herstellen und zeigt euch hier vorne
sieht zutaten wird der mehrbetrag
brauche ich 150 gramm kalte butter 60
gramm puderzucker etwas vanille extrakt
einen teelöffel zimt eine prise salz
bajnai und 250 gramm mehl und für die
füllung habe ich hier 100 gramm
pistazien und 400 gramm marzipanrohmasse
und ich sehe da am liebsten immer die
lübecker marzipanrohmasse weil die
einfach qualität ich am besten ist das
spiel wandel anteil drin weniger zucker
und es schlägt einfach super ich werde
ich zuerst einmal den maps herstellen
und ich mache es jetzt in der
küchenmaschine aber ihr könnt natürlich
auch den teig mit den händen oder mit
einem handrührgerät zum beispiel
verkneten
zuerst kommt die kälte rein und anil
extrakt salz und zimt und die zutaten
werden jetzt kurz miteinander verrührt
[Musik]
jetzt kommt noch dazu und zum schluss
auch noch das leben
[Musik]
jetzt ist der teig schön verbunden und
ich kann ihn jetzt rausnehmen zu einer
kugel formen und dann muss ich eben zwei
stunden kühl und in der zeit habe ich
dann schon mal die pistazien fein hacken
[Musik]
und die pistazien und knete ich jetzt
noch in die marzipanrohmasse ein und
wartet dann einfach noch kurzfristig
abgekühlt ist
[Musik]
der track ist jetzt gut durch gekühlt
und jetzt werde ich ihnen zu einem
großen rechteck ausrollen
[Musik]
das habe ich ein schönes rechteck das
hat ungefähr die maße 30 x 45 cm ohne
zwei dritteln
das heißt wir durchschneiden und bei
einmalig wie hier
und werdet aus diesem marzipan gemisch
also mal abgefahren und pistazien das
war nicht jetzt auch drittel und jeweils
eine rolle mit 30 cm durchmesser formen
[Musik]
jetzt bestreitet den teig mit etwas
wasser und rolle dann die marken rolle
ein
[Musik]
jetzt kann man diese drei rollen auf ein
backblech schon zwar nehme ich da wieder
das perforierte backblech mit den
löchern und einer back folien
[Musik]
und so werden die rollen jetzt bei 180
grad für etwa 20 minuten gebacken und
danach hatte ich sie komplett ab
die rollen sind jetzt abgekühlt ich
hatte dir auf einem abkühlen gitter
und jetzt werde ich sie in 1 cm breite
scheiben schneiden
da müsst ihr nur aufpassen dass ihr das
messer einmal ansetzt und unterdrückt
ansonsten können sie leicht brechen und
ich bin zwar leicht verschnupft also
ganz leicht aber man riecht trotzdem was
ich trotzdem das marzipan und auch die
pistazien riecht wirklich super und
jetzt könnt ihr sie entweder so lassen
mit dem zuckerguss überziehen oder ihr
macht es jetzt so wie ich so sehen sie
jetzt erst mal von innen aus also
richtig hübsch mit diesem bis thaksin
kam und ich werde sie jetzt aber mit
etwas zeit mit der kuvertüre bestreichen
ich finde es passt einfach geschmacklich
super zum abschied und pistazie die
kuvertüre habe ich bereits temperiert
also verschmolzen und habe auch hier die
restlichen ist tatsächlich noch hatte
feine ganz grob gehabt nicht sein
jetzt kommt da nur so ein ganz kleiner
tags also gerade über eine ecke wo und
da stehe ich dann gleich noch die
pistazien frauen
[Musik]
pistazien plätzen sind jetzt so fertig
die müssen jetzt noch ein bisschen
trocknen das geht entweder hier bei
zimmertemperatur oder stellte einfach
ganz kurz in den kühlschrank und dann
sollten sie aufpassen wenn ihr sie
verpackt im so eine keksdose wieder oben
dass er immer eine schicht pistazien
plätzchen hat und dann so eine schicht
backpapier oder pergamentpapier
dazwischen damit einfach dieser schöne
optik nicht kaputt geht und dann keine
krümmel hier oben auf der oberfläche
landen und das eben nicht kaputt gehen
die sind nämlich wirklich sehr zart und
ich habe soeben schon probiert und die
schmecken wirklich ganz toll nach
pistazien nach marzipan und die zarte
schokolade für mich unterstützt den
geschmackvoll kommen
ich finde die ähneln geschmacklich so
ein bisschen an die mozartkugeln den wir
auf die starts im marzipan und
zartbitterschokolade deswegen finde ich
sehr gut
und falls er dieses rezept nach machen
wollt geht auch sally potters stehen
noch ganz genau
und ganz besonders toll finde ich bei
diesem plätzchen dass man kein
besonderes werkzeug brauchen keine
besonderen ausreiche es geht wirklich
alles so ganz einfach also viel spaß
beim nachmachen und bis zum nächsten mal
bis bald
[Musik]